you're looking at the oldest color film
on her shot by Edward Turner in 1901 and
what better way to show off your
world-changing invention than with a
parrot today we take for granted the
staggering number of colors we see on
screen but it's taken a whole lot of
ingenious hacking to get here before
inventors like Turner figure out how to
capture color on film filmmakers were
painting their footage frame by frame
the results were stunning but as you can
imagine a bit labor-intensive director
George Mele a hired a whole assembly
line of women just to paint his films
like the iconic movie a trip to the moon
others utilized tinting to avoid the
expense of hand coloring some filmmakers
figure out how to capture color on
multiple strips of film but found it
incredibly difficult to projector
kinemacolor solve this problem by using
a clever optical illusion each frame was
shot alternatively with a red or green
filter then projected again through an
alternating red and green filter our
persistence of vision combined the
alternating colors even though it only
used two colors the resulting image
should look remarkably natural still
those films had a problem with fringing
those red and green trails and the lack
of blue was very apparent meanwhile
Technicolor developed a whole new
process to capture natural color
using a beam splitter with a
semipermeable mirror in the center
Technicolor was able to capture three
colors on three separate strips those
were all pressed onto the same clear
strip leaving behind a full-color image
on a single piece of film this gave rise
to one of cinema's most powerful moments
in 1939 The Wizard of Oz that moment
that Dorothy opens the door to Oz and
the film color shifts from a dusty sepia
to a rich and vibrant full spectrum
Technicolor color goes beyond
representing the natural world it
becomes a part of the story that moment
assured in a whole new era of filmmaking
[Music]
it was until 1951 that Kodak introduced
Eastman color which quickly beat out
Technicolor mostly because it was easier
to use and way cheaper unfortunately it
wasn't very good at retaining color so
most films will be reprinted by
Technicolor superior process not a whole
lot change for several decades until
this hotness the live-action film Super
Mario Bros the first folding feature to
use digital intermediates surprisingly
digital processing survived back
disaster and now just about every major
motion picture gets its finishing
touches done in digital space a famous
example of this is comb brothers oh
brother where art thou one of the first
films to leverage digital process to
achieve that uniquely dusty de saturated
look
you had been in this world before where
you only had the option when film to
make things brighter or darker or red or
green or blue and that was it
that's Steve Scott the supervising
finishing artist at Technicolor you've
probably never heard of him but you've
definitely seen this work yes of course
I had my auspicious debut with the
Coneheads movie Apollo 13 interview with
the vampire Titanic Iron Man The
Avengers movies and guardians of the
galaxy Birdman the revenant gravity
those last three all won Academy Awards
in cinematography
this is him working on a more recent
project Doctor Strange he wanted to see
a little more detail in the black Steve
is able to finesse every little detail
from the shadows on Tilda Swinton's
space to the little beads of light
falling through the window he also
prepared the film in HDR or high dynamic
range the latest advancement in image
projection which allows us to see more
detail than ever before usually when you
see a black screen you don't really see
black you see kind of a lifted black
think of it this way you have a gradient
from black to white imagine you can only
see a portion of that HDR allows you to
see a full range
this advancement gives filmmakers a
wider range of lights for quit than ever
before
it's the biggest leap in display and
projection and monitors I've seen since
I've been in this business the
technology is still pretty new and a bit
hard to come by but that's changing
they'll be recently partnered with AMC
to outfit dozens of theaters with its
Dolby vision laser projectors there's
generally only one or two films in Dolby
vision at any given theatre but you'll
be seeing a lot more in the near future
[Music]